while the omicron variant so
transmissible spreading so rapidly
there's a need for more testing
locations ymca of southern nevada
operating several across the valley
madison kimbrough joining us live from
one of them it is the heinrich ymca and
meadows lane right across the mall and
it's closing right now for the night
madison
but as you can see there are cars still
behind me we've been here since noon you
can take a look this drive-through
testing site opened at eight and as of
now it's looking like close to 50 cars
in line at the moment which is nothing
compared to what we've seen at other
sites across the valley
i got a phone call that i got exposure
and then
i started losing my taste today people
here in line expressing how relieved
they are to have found a testing site i
went on every site on the internet and
nobody has any locations luckily stacy
found this the y offering covet 19 drive
through testing here at heinrich as well
as skyview and centennial hills
locations we actually got a notification
on our local
paradise palms website saying that the
line wasn't bad here and that the
residents should come here and try it so
that's why we're here ymca of southern
nevada partnered with has tech to offer
these free coven 19 pcr tests there's no
appointment needed and results come back
in two to three days just want to be
safe for me and my family i don't you
know i did have cobit one time before
and it's not a good feeling people were
at my house recently and i've been
coming to find out one of those people
who's at my house one of their family
members had it but they didn't know so i
want to make sure i'm good again this
location is on meadows lane across from
the mall the other two centennial hills
ymca on buffalo and 95 and skyview ymca
on centennial parkway near losey in
north las vegas
this location closed at six tonight but
will reopen this weekend from eight
until four now these drive-throughs have
actually been open a few weeks now but
not many knew about them the y just sent
the info out to its members and alerted
us to it today they also shared that
these sites will be open for the
foreseeable future as long as there is a
need we'll have all the times and
locations up on our website reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now